start again because of the evil lady the
the mother the wife
ABAB there's too many of them here so
why we say my dear brothers and sisters
we don't just come here and debate and
have discussions likewise we teach the
Muslims you know and this something
which aldah distinguish
the that they teach so you know
ration what what protect Islam from his
guidance or from people try to to it
that people of Sunnah any Muslim try to
say something wrong about Islam they
refute him and when they refute him
doesn't mean he's not a Muslim anymore
or he's going to go to Hellfire or he
must be evil and everything no okay
because there's difference between uh uh
reputation and warning and innovator so
anyway one of the principles of inov
people of innovation and misguidance
that they are utilizing to shut down
people of Sunnah they say if you're
going to refute someone you must mention
is good you must
L you have to mention it's good and this
principle you don't have to okay was ask
if it's needed no problem but you don't
have to you don't not cuz sometimes what
can happen if you start refuting someone
and if submission is good what happen
you confuse people you see and when you
when you when we refute someone a Muslim
doesn't mean he has no good with him the
good that he did is between him and
Allah but the time that we are refuting
him we're trying to clarify the truth
okay so don't start writing comment
section many people become Muslims
through him he refus liberalism no we
not brother is a time of we we're not
here to write biography if you're going
to write someone's biography even you
don't agree with him you have to mention
everything about him do you understand
that so there's many principles that
people Innovation misguidance who
hate refutation criticize and praise
they bring to shut down people of Sunnah
the reason I mentioned that few few days
back I made a video against Dan this
brother who is on a mission to lie
against slander them and lie against
them some brother said you is good I
said listen brother I know this man is B
you see but I'm just mentioning in case
some people try to utilize and against
us he's a Muslim no doubt but don't try
to say oh they believe all the Muslims
are in the hell fire that is a
lie all of them said no you don't have
to mention someone good when is Battle
will Allah refute ABAB ABAB has some
good with him Allah not mention his Good
Will Allah refute
n those who Allah cursed them they they
didn't do good no good they did good but
it's not the time to mention they good
do you understand that so we have to
learn my dear brothers and sisters
knowledge is very important especially
the time we're living in the time of
social media many people cannot sit down
and read two pag from a book many people
cannot do that anymore 1 minute that's
it rather there was a study that Oxford
University majority of people that watch
YouTube videos the longest they do watch
maurity how you know how long 25 minutes
after that they interest Subhan Allah
and we are people of the book meaning
that we the books have Quran so we have
to try to utilize our time to study
because the knowledge is in the books
and knowledge before in the books is in
the chest of the scholars do you
understand that my dear brothers may
Allah bless you all if you don't agree
you can speak I'm not here to if you
think I said is wrong we can discuss it
because the way of the we for the Quran
and theah and the way of the so this
principle in order to refute someone you
have to mention is good is false
principle
because if someone mentioned it out of
there's no problem with that but if you
say you have to
it's and may Allah bless you all and I
have to go anywhere because and I have
to do some stuff inshallah I was going
to come today but I said let me come and
by the way next week inshallah I will be
in Bradford I will be in Mah in Bradford
we're going to be with our brothers M
Sunnah in Bradford inshallah next week
coming to the mjid inshah to give a talk
about we Muslims are in need of Islam
our youth you are in need of Islam we
have to understand without Islam we are
nothing if you are seeking honor honor
is in Islam if you're seeking respect is
in Islam if you are seeking success is
in Islam success of this life and day
after and I don't want to speak about in
details because he's going to be I'm
going to expose my everything so I'll be
giving a lecture in next Saturday in
Bradford in the evening you can check on
our YouTube channel
bless